that's probably the most fun I've had on
a movie again early in my career 20s but
a big cast of people in the same place
we just had the greatest Vibe with
everybody I think that basically
trickled down from Edgar and the energy
that he was creating and we all got to
rehearse together and spend a lot of
time together the rehearsal was so fun
and you leave and come back a month
later to do your bit and you just have
such horrible fomo you just you know
what you guys been doing if you've been
having fun send me pictures by the end
of the movie I felt like this is this is
my world this is my group of friends it
kind of feels like oh this is always
going to be this way and I honestly I
kind of was a little depressed when we
were done because um
you know it all just goes away leaving
was heartbreaking it truly was like the
first time I was like I mean I can just
hang out guys if you need me to you know
it's you don't want to miss a beat I was
sad to lose it I could have kept making
that forever yeah to this day that email
chain is still very active